what up space fam golden here from anime
opera and today we are talking about one
of the most hyped aspects of one piece
bounties and specifically luffy's
growing bounty and what it will be after
defeating kaido so make sure to stay
tuned for this one if you do enjoy these
one-piece videos and want to keep them
coming you know what to do channel
parking within and smash that like
button be a smashing pirate king rather
than a passing orochi if you haven't
joined the nakama by making this the
video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates welcome
aboard and now without further ado let's
jump into it spoilers and all before we
get to luffy's new bounty it will help
if we explore his past bounties and how
they evolved over the course of the
story luffy's first bounty was 30
million berries during chapter 96 called
the meanest man in the east commander
brand new at navy headquarters explains
how luffy beat buggy who was worth 15
million don krieg who was worth 17
million and arlong who was worth 20
million the average reward in the east
blue is 3 million berries but since each
of these pirates was worth over 10
million berries they're giving luffy a
starting bounty of 30 million they say
it's unprecedented but they believe it
is necessary to nip this evil in the bud
before it spreads it's still hilarious
to me how bringing down corrupt pirates
makes him evil but that's a discussion
for another video luffy's bounty started
off 50
higher than that of his most recent
defeated opponent orlon yes his bounty
took buggy and don creek into account as
well but it's still interesting to note
how high his bounty goes up compared to
that of the people he beat luffy's next
bounty is dropped during chapter 213
after he defeats one of the seven
warlords of the sea namely crocodile
this is a huge deal because the warlord
system was one of the balancing powers
of the world like dianko and luffy just
beat one before he became a warlord
crocodile had a bounty of 81 million the
former bounty suggests it might be even
higher by now if he didn't become a
warlord but that's just speculation so
we'll work with the figure that we have
luffy's own bounty like last time jumps
well past his defeated opponent's bounty
and lands at a very impressive 100
million berries this time his bounty is
about 25 percent higher than that of his
most recent defeated opponent things get
less straightforward with the next
bounty because luffy fights rob lucci
before he gets it rather than a pirate
with a measurable bounty after defeating
the marine's own man cp 9's strongest
member in history luffy's new boutique
is revealed during chapter 435 it's 300
million berries this raises another
interesting aspect about bounties the
world government issues them based on
their perceived threat level of a given
pirate so being a threat to the world
government and their established order
rather than just a strong dude who never
interferes with the marines will mean
that you get a much higher bounty in
theory so since luffy beat one of the
marine strong fighters rather than just
a pirate it's no surprise his bounty
shot up so much here this is another
aspect to keep in mind when discussing
what his newest bounty will be next
let's fast forward to chapter 601 where
luffy's fourth bounty is revealed to be
400 million this is post time skip and
marine ford where luffy helped break
prisoners out of impel down people found
out he's the world's worst criminals aka
monkey d dragon's son he escaped the war
with the help of whitebeard and shanks
and so on you might ask why his bounty
didn't go up more since this is the
smallest jump so far percentage-wise
well i'm guessing it's because he wasn't
that powerful at marine ford he failed
to rescue his brother he broke down and
he had to be saved if he succeeded at
marineford you can bet his bounty would
have gone up way more this bounty is
also like immediately outdated at least
power wise because it doesn't account
for how much more dangerous he became
strength-wise after his two years of
training after defeating doflamingo at
dressrosa luffy's bounty goes up to half
a billion berries which to me is a much
more important milestone than 400
million despite it not being the biggest
increase luffy had already beaten the
warlord before and warlord doflamingo's
former bounty was 340 million so less
than luffy's was when he beat him
despite how epic it was seeing luffy
beat such a strong awakened fruit user
the above mentioned details help explain
why his bounty didn't blow up
significantly after this victory that
leads us to luffy's current bounty which
jumped from half a billion all the way
to 1.5 billion aka it increased by three
times or 200 percent this was after his
defeat of big mom's strongest commander
charlotte katakuri whose bounty was
1.057 billion so luffy's bounty
increased to be about 50 percent higher
than katakuri's it wasn't just that
fight that raised his bounty though
since he was viewed as the ringleader of
an attempt to assassinate yonko big mom
as well and lived to tell the tale
furthermore sanji's bounty went up to
330 million and former warlord jimbei
joined his crew as well and since jimbei
has an amazing bounty of
million it all reflects well on luffy
leaving him to be viewed as a bigger
threat the grand fleet of over 5 000
pirates aka the seven powerful pirate
crews under his sway were also mentioned
along with the fact that he wasn't just
ace's brother but sabos as well which is
significant because sabo is the number
two of the revolutionaries arguably the
most dangerous organization to the world
government and i mean the list goes on
but the point is he not only confronted
a yonko crew but came out the better of
the two which along with all of his
other feats that came before justified
the 1.5 billion barry bounty and even
earned him the title of the fifth
emperor of the sea that's when he got
his current bounty but so much has
changed since then in a big way remember
even with this bounty of 1.5 billion and
with the title of the fifth emperor
luffy got wrecked by yonko kaido in
their first one-on-one however since
that loss his mastery of haki and his
master of his own devil fruit has gone
up to an insane degree and in an
insanely short period of time i mean
this dude is 19 and he's already given
kaido the so-called strongest creature
in the world and the living yaako with
the highest bounty an insanely good
fight now i think it's clear that
luffy's victory will be confirmed
eventually but i just want to say that
he's already accomplished insane things
people say bet on kaido in a one-on-one
whoever the opponent is and yet our 19
year old protagonist is giving him a run
for his money but for the sake of coming
up with his next bounty we need to look
to post wano and post his defeat of
kaido so let's see what that could mean
for luffy's next bounty we've seen that
a bounty incorporates a lot of factors
including an individual's solo strength
their crew strength their threat level
to the world government and so on let's
start by looking at kaido's bounty which
is
4.611 billion bearings if luffy beats
him how high can we expect his to go
don't worry this isn't the only factor
i'll take into account but it is an
important and fun one when he beat
arlong his bounty increased to be 50
percent higher than arlong's when he
beat crocodile his bounty increased to
be about 25 percent higher than
crocodile's own bounty when he beat
katakuri it increased to be about 50
percent higher than katakuri's bounty so
when taking kaido's roughly 4.6 billion
bounty into account we get a range from
5.75 billion which is 25 higher than
kaidos to 6.9 billion which is 50 higher
than kaido's now at this point you might
be thinking this is too high bro goldie
roger the pirate king was
5.5648 billion berries there's no way
luffy's bounty will surpass that so soon
you might be thinking and yet on the
lower end of the range i gave luffy is
already ahead of roger the pirate king
with a bounty of 5.75 billion and
honestly i know this might sound crazy
at first but there is little doubt in my
mind that luffy will surpass the pirate
king's own bounty and it's not just
because of inflation i strongly believe
he'll become the man with the highest
bounty ever dead or alive we saw how
that could potentially be justified if
we just take his historical bounty data
and how it went up in relation to that
of his conquered opponents in the past
but there are so many other reasons that
luffy will become the most wanted man
ever after wano another reason is his
crew everybody is gonna get spikes and
bounty after this especially zorro zoro
blocked a combined yonko attack gave
kaido a lasting scar launched attack so
dangerous that kaido and big mom felt
the need to dodge and then went on to
beat king kaido's strongest man who has
a 1.39 billion bounty zorro's own bounty
even though he's not the captain should
easily surpass luffy's current bounty of
1.5 billion post wanna in other words
zorro alone will have a higher bounty
than the so-called fifth emperor has
right now meaning it'll be like luffy's
crew has at least two emperors on it if
luffy doesn't get his own special title
afterwards but in my view the most
important aspect to look at when
determining luffy's post wanna bounty is
the threat he poses to the world
government luffy right now is by far the
biggest threat to the world government
we've seen and that's counting the
pirate king even before he awakened his
fruit the government wanted to kill him
at all costs fearing the potential of
his awakening that's why they were
willing to lose one of their best cp
zero agents and even angered the
strongest creature in the world to do it
however they failed to stop him from
awakening despite their best efforts
luffy awakened and we all found out that
he didn't have the gum gum fruit but
rather he had the mythical zone sun god
nika fruit the most ridiculous power in
the world to quote the world government
just the legend of nika alone was enough
to make a jail guard who was talking
about the sun god disappear who's who
remembers that nika was a figure that
slaves would pray to in the long distant
past a legendary warrior they believed
would one day free them they thought
he'd bring smiles to their faces and
deliver them from suffering who's who as
different from luffy and his friends as
he is even admitted to clinging to the
legend of nikka because prison felt so
endless such a unifying figure for
slaves and the oppressed is the world
government's worst nightmare and even
the story was enough to make who's whose
jailer disappear and to make him fear
for his own life he feared that they'd
make him disappear so much that he
risked it all to escape and that's how
he ended up joining kaido's crew since
even knowing about the legend is deadly
then having a living and breathing sun
god nika in luffy giving hope strength
and even assistance to downtrodden is
probably the biggest threat that the
world government has ever encountered
with his cartoonish fruit luffy can
straight up do the impossible or in
other words make miracles happen which
is sure to further inspire the people
that the world government rules over to
rise up roger couldn't be such a threat
because he didn't have this fruit he
also knew that he was too early so at
some point he probably decided to leave
the world government to do what they
were doing for his lifetime at least
trusting that another would take care of
it in fact goldie roger teamed up with
monkey d garp and the marines to help
protect nobles from rox d zebek at god
valley or at least that's the story we
got so not only was roger not as much of
a threat to the world government we know
he even teamed up with them on at least
one occasion luffy we know doesn't care
about people's status he's already
punched a celestial dragon in the face
he cannot be controlled and will do the
right thing and the right thing for him
is in almost every case being a warrior
of liberation and liberating people
wherever he goes which again is the
worst thing for an organization that
wants to rule over and control people
finally beyond his insane power the
insane power of his crew and alliances
which by the way now include marco the
phoenix which i didn't even mention and
his sun god nika status luffy also has
connections with shanks the man who
stopped the paramount war after stopping
kaido from going after whitebeard as
well and probably more importantly has
connections to revolutionaries his
father is monkey d dragon the world's
worst criminal and his brother is the
second in command sabo although dragon
and luffy haven't done a lot together so
far with this new sun god nika the war
of liberation reveal luffy is the
perfect symbol for the revolutionaries
to support and rally behind after this
dragon should have every reason in the
world to team up with and help luffy
because sun god luffy is the one more
than any other that can make his dream
of liberating people from the world
government and celestial dragons come
true those are just his well-established
connections but beyond that mihawk noted
that luffy has the ability to make
allies of those around him and that's
the most dangerous ability in this
entire ocean so the world government can
assume that he'll keep gaining more and
more dangerous allies like a snowball
rolling down an endless snowy hill
becoming exponentially bigger over time
so with all these aspects in mind in my
view a bounty range from 5.75 billion
which again is 25 percent higher than
kaido's 26.9 billion which is 50 higher
than kaido's is more reasonable and in
fact i'd say it's on the lower end of
what his new bounty could potentially be
if we take into account all of the facts
we've covered in this video i would
honestly not be surprised if luffy
jumped to a ridiculous 10 billion barry
bounty to match his ridiculous new power
but at the very least i think he should
have the highest bounty we've ever seen
because i've shown he's a much bigger
threat to the world government than even
roger was smash that like button if you
enjoyed this video be a smashing pirate
king rather than a passing orochi make
this the video you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one-piece videos and updates check out
my big one-piece playlist that includes
videos on the yonko warlords admirals
and much more link to that is in the
description let me know what do you
think will be luffy's new postswano
bounty and if someone gets it right
after the reveal i'll try to shout them
out in a future chapter review or in
another one piece video thanks so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys